[Music]
in a 1677 letter to the royal society of
london
the dutch tradesman and microbiology
pioneer anthony van lievenhoek
described the strange appendages he had
found on a creature in a sample of
rainwater
he observed the organism was quote
provided with divers incredibly thin
little feet or little legs which were
moved
very nimbly we don't know exactly what
organism he was describing
just that it was some sort of ciliated
protozoan
but this letter is important because the
little legs
he was describing constitute one of the
earliest descriptions
of a cellular organelle
levenhook was referring to cilia the
name would be bestowed in 1786
by otto muller who took inspiration from
the word psyllium which translates
to eyelash in latin today we know that
cilia
are a bundle of microtubules and that
the synchronized beating of
motile cilia can create currents in the
water
we can often see cilia in action waving
around
along the edges of a single cell
eukaryote as they move around
or even crowning more complex organisms
like rotifers to help them gather food
so sometimes cilia are a way to move
around
and sometimes they're a way to eat and
sometimes they are both
but sometimes they let an organism lead
the most
ideal lifestyle of all one
where you just hang out and let the food
come to you
one group of ciliates that manages to
strive toward
that ideal are the peritrix ciliates
a diverse group of protists that contain
around a thousand
species that number making about a
seventh of all
ciliates we currently know about
peritric ciliates
are characterized by their vase-like
shape
or depending on where you're from
vaz-like shape
which opens into an enlarged mouth-like
structure
called the peristome that is lined with
what else
cilia one of the most well-studied
peritrix ciliates
are vorticella whose cilia you can see
waving around here
their peristomes are lined with two
bands of cilia one to generate water
currents and to draw food towards their
mouthy thing and another to filter
through the particles
and it turns out that all that movement
is quite effective
scientists measuring some vorticella
found that even when their cilia
are only 17 micrometers long
they can bring in particles that were
450
micrometers away imagine
if they were a delicious snack 50 feet
away from you
and all you had to do was a wave your
arms in the air
morticella truly living the dream
we featured vorticella on a recent
episode where we followed them
in real time as they dealt with rude
neighbors
and other little microcosmic things
we were able to film that episode
because vorticella belong
to the larger order of peritrix ciliates
called
the sicilia which as the name suggests
are all scessile that means for most of
their life
sicilied peritrix ciliates are found
attached to other surfaces
be they rock plant or something else
in contrast the rest of the paratroop
ciliates are grouped together as members
of the free swimming mobilita
of course while these distinctions are
useful things are not necessarily as
neat as
these organisms swim and these organisms
don't
sicilid paritrix live their lives in one
of
two distinct forms the dominant one
the one that defines them is their adult
sessile form
which is called the trophant stage the
trophant cecilid
is attached to a surface like the
forticella using its long
stock to stake its place and its body
lacks any cilia except for those
distinct bands
around their peristome but in their
youth
cecilia peritrix are free swimmers
called teletrokes
in contrast to their trophon stages
these teletrokes
usually don't feed so their oral
cilia are tucked away but they do have
a single band of cilia around their
bodies
called the trocal band which helps them
swim around
until they find something to attach to
while the teletroke is generally
associated with
young cecilia peritrix a trophant
can return to this stage if it needs to
find a new home
like this campanella that's decided to
leave its stock
and swim off somewhere new
[Music]
and just like cecilia peritrix do
sometimes move around
there are so-called mobilitrics with an
adhesive
disk that allows them to attach to
things
but unlike cecilids mobilids never
lose their trocal cilia that help them
swim around
and when they swim around they really do
put the mobile and mobilid
i can barely keep this one in the frame
the evolutionary lines connecting these
two orders are vague there have been
hypotheses that mobilide paritrix
evolved from the swimming teletroke
stage of the cecilia life cycle
but attempts to use molecular phylogeny
to verify that prediction at a genetic
level
have come up with varied results so
there's a chance
that these different organisms are
related but they
also may be two unrelated groups of
organisms who
stumbled on the same ciliated oral
structure
through convergent evolution
order they belong to the peritrix
ciliates
that do attach to a substrate make for
an interesting study
part of it is the way they bring their
own drama
to what seems like a dull sedentary life
you might have noticed this in our real
time episode where the vorticella
rapidly contracted and responsed to
passing organisms
when this happens a vorticella's stock
can collapse to around 20 to 40 percent
of its original length
in milliseconds a fast movement that is
followed eventually
by a much slower and more chill
relaxation
back to full length in his own
observation of vorticella
leavenhook noted that he found this site
mightily diverting
[Music]
but the choices that peritrix ciliates
make
in where to set up their stocks can be
mightily diverting
as well sometimes it's the typical
substrates things like
plants or rocks but sometimes it's
animals
sometimes these interactions can become
more fraught
mobilid paretrix for example are known
to infect
fishes and amphibians creating both
ecological
and economic challenges but when these
interactions aren't harmful
you get something called epibiosis
where an organism lives on another
organism without being parasitic
and judging by the many varied animal
homes that peritrix ciliates have chosen
they're not particularly picky like
these ciliates
that have found a place on this water
flea to cozy up to
some have been found in the gills of
blue crabs
others on tardigrades and snails
and pelagic diatoms and the antenna of
european crayfish
the list truly goes on
[Music]
in a way that has delighted us for
centuries
using those tiny little legs in their
mouths and along their bodies
peritric ciliates have managed to carve
out a very specific
and some might say ideal way of life
that seems to have helped them survive
just about anywhere thank you for coming
on this journey with us
as we explore the unseen world that
surrounds us
journey to the micro cosmos is produced
by complexly
and this is a bit of a left turn but if
you are a us citizen and want to not
only
keep imagining the world complexly but
also
have a voice in your government check
out how to vote in every state
the rules for voting are different
depending on where you live in the u.s
so we've made a whole series explaining
how to vote in each state
as well as some advice for special cases
like territories and overseas voters
check out our 2020 guide at youtube.com
how to vote in every state if you like
what we do here at journey to the
microcosmos
we deeply appreciate that and we want to
thank all the people
on the screen right now for helping make
that possible these
are our patrons on patreon if you want
to join them
check out patreon.com journey2micro
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss check out jam
and germs on instagram
and if you want to see more from us
there's usually a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
you